- We're back with Brian
Crisen and Rita Wilson.
Everybody give it up.
- [Kelly] So both Brian and Rita
and I of course have had
music as a central theme
to our lives.
So we thought it would
be fun to talk about some
of the songs that are
most meaningful to us.
And we downloaded Brian's
and Rita's personal playlist
'cause we're stalkers' and we
put it into our super computer
and it's time to ask them about
some of their favorite songs
with a round of playlist shuffle.
(guitar playing)
Oh, I love that.
That's such good graphic.
- Yes, there we go.
- Love it.
- Well, Emmy Award-winning this show.
Rita, thank you so much Justin.
Thank you.
All right, so I'm gonna
hit this button and our,
and I'm gonna move the, move it closer
'cause I've got short arms.
Our super computer will randomly shuffle
through their playlist
and whoever's song is
selected will tell us about
their love of the song.
So let's see why.
Here we go.
- Oh my god.
Love it.
- Here we go.
This song is first.
- Oh.
- Oh
- That's a good one.
- That one's mine.
Unless you have the same one.
- [Rita] I do.
- Are you joking.
- I do love this song.
I love Simon & Garfunkel.
Here let's see, Mrs. Robinson.
Simon and Garfunkel
soundtracks of our youth.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- This was a seminal moment to me of
assertiveness or lack thereof.
I had a crush on a girl
named Carolyn Kesole
and I wanted to ask her out or, you know
in those days I was in sixth
grade and you would just say
do you want to go steady, right away?
Yeah, you know steady.
And then you'd give him a
Saint Christopher metal.
- [Rita] Oh my God.
- Did you remember doing that?
- Yes, I had a turquoise, from Brad.
- [Kelly] You did a what?
- It's a Christopher Medel.
- Metal.
It meant you're going steady with a guy.
- [Rita] Yes exactly, yeah.
- [Kelly] You just
bring religion right in.
- [Brian] I know.
- I like it, I like it.
- I don't what it meant,
but, and that's what it was.
And unfortunately at a party,
I hesitated and some new guy
in his class walked right
up to her and said, you wanna go steady?
And she said, yes.
I went, and that song was playing.
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- And everything started going
in slow motion at that time.
And it was like, oh my
God, that just happened.
And I was like
- So wait, so wait.
- Wow, that was so nice.
- So wait, do you like
do you like going to these
nostalgic sad moments often?
- [Rita] Yes.
- All of my songs are so sad.
- I love that song.
Okay, wait, let's see another one.
That was a great story.
- [Rita] That's so good.
- Oh, well this might be one of y'all,
but it's also me.
- Oh my, Is it.
- I adore Linda Ronstadt.
- It's good, (indistinct) like beyond.
- [Kelly] She sings anything.
- Anything.
Yeah.
What about this one?
- This is, you're no good.
- No, but why do you like this one?
- I know this one.
- You're no good.
- I think we've done this song.
- Baby you're no good.
We got a band going.
- Feeling better.
- Go ahead.
- Now that we're through.
- [Kelly] With that rasp
- Feeling better.
(all singing)
- Since I'm Over You.
- I can't remember the words.
I'm like teleprompter, teleprompter.
- I mean just that beat.
- Oh.
- And you know what,
it was so empowering to
hear a woman sing.
You're no good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Basically like I'm standing
up, I'm taking the bull
by the horns.
You were no good.
And I'm telling you, you are no good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like I love that.
- And her voice.
Just so strong and powerful.
- Hearing Universal Studios.
There was an amphitheater called
the Universal Amphitheater
and it was a music venue.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was a ticket
taker at the amphitheater.
And once you took the
tickets, you could go
and watch the show and
then when the show is over
you have to clean the bathrooms.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It doesn't matter
because you got to watch
every show that came in.
- Wow.
- So I saw you see her.
I saw her like eight nights in a row.
Oh my Joni Mitchell,
Linda Ronstadt, Carol King
James Taylor, the Eagles
everybody came through there and yes, yes.
That's kind of very sad
that that venue is gone
with all those icons.
- Well it was magical.
It was a magical place.
- [Kelly] That's, I would've
- [Rita] except it's
- [Kelly] I'd still
clean toilets to watch.
I would do it right now.
I gotta do it at home anyway.
All right, well that is the
playlist shuffle everybody.
You're welcome for all the rad music
be sure to check out Rita's new album.
Rita Wilson now and Forever duets.
And also watch Brian show,
Your Honor on Showtime.